[موسيقى]
متدحرجه في زمن قياسي بنك سيليكون فالي في
الولايات المتحده في عين الاعصار انهار
بين عشيه وضحاها مع موجه سحب وصفت
بتسونامي البنك مقرض رئيس لقطاعي التقنيه
وشركات الرياضيه الناشئه وترتيبه 17 بين
اكبر البنوك الامريكيه من حيث حجم
الميزانيه يملك نحو 209 مليارات دولار من
الاصول ونحو 175 مليار دولار من الودائع
ما الذي حدث بدا الامر الاربعاء الماضي
حيث هزت المستثمرين اعلانات لاداره البنك
ببيعها 21 مليار دولار من الاستثمارات وهو
ما ادى الى خساره بنحو مليار و800 مليون
دولار ولاحقا فجاء البنك مستثمري بالحاجه
لجمع مليارين وربع مليار دولار لدعم
ميزانيته وتسبب ذلك في رده فعل سلبيه
للمذيعين ازداد الغموض مع كشف الرئيس
التنفيذي للبنك بريك بيكر في رساله
للمذيعين والمستثمرين عن سعيه الاقتراض
خمسه عشر مليار دولار مما كان مخططا له في
الاصل برر البنك خطواته بتاثره سلبا برفع
اسعار الفائده التي رفعها الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي 8 مرات من العام الماضي وضغوط
السوق الاخرى وانخفاض اسعار السندات ليصبح
البنك مكشوفا لكن كل ذلك تحصيل وضع هش
للبنك فهنا يمكن عبر المنحنى البياني
ملاحظه تراجع نشاط الايداع والسحب في
البنك الذي اضحى سالبا منذ اكثر من عام
وهو مؤشر يكشف ما حدث لاحقا تسببت رده فعل
المستثمرين والعملاء وموجه السحب في تراجع
السهم البنك في تداول الخميس بنحو 60% وب
20% في تداول بعد السوق صباح الجمعه جاء
قرار الجهه المنظمه للخدمه المصرفيه بوقف
التداول في اسهم البنك وحجز ودائع عملائه
واعتبر الانهيار اكبر فشل مؤسسي تواجهه
السلطات الماليه الامريكيه منذ الازمه
الماليه العالميه لعام 2008 وانهيار بنك
لممبرز في انت التدخل لتقليل المخاطر
انهيار البنك بدات داعيته بانتقال حاله
قلق الى فروعه في الصين والدنمارك
والمانيا والهند واسرائيل والسويد
والمملكه المتحده وغيرها خسرت اكبر اربعه
مصارف امريكيه عشره المليارات من
الدولارات في البورصات الخميس واعقبتها
المصارف الاسيويه ثم الاوروبيه كما حذر
اكثر من 200 من رؤساء الشركات التكنولوجيا
في المملكه المتحده الحكومه من مواجهه ما
سموه تهديدا وجوديا بسبب التعاملهم مع بنك
السيليكون فالي ودعوها للتدخل وتحدث رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين تينياهو عن
ازمه عميقه لصناعه التكنولوجيا الفائقه مع
التعامل عدد كبير من الشركات الاسرائيليه
مع البنك وامتدت شظايا الانهيار الى عمله
يو اس تي كوين المشفره المرتبطه بالدولار
التي فقدت جزءا كبيرا من قيمتها وتراجعت
الى ادنى مستوى لها على الاطلاق يوم السبت
وفق الشركه المصدره لها